now to a dramatic scene at the United
Nations as teenage activist Greta toon
burg scolded world leaders for their
inaction on climate change
her powerful speech came as a new report
is set to detail the grim state of the
world's health like melting glaciers
mark Phillips is in Monaco where that
report will be released mark what can we
expect good morning after the science
comes the politics delegates have been
working all night in the building behind
me on the wording of the latest United
Nations Climate Change report spoiler
alert here the news isn't good
it's been a week of highly charged
emotional debate that's the special UN
climate summit in New York
it wasn't government leaders it was the
sweetest teenager Greta tune Berg who
stole the show
there wasn't much stealing to do from
President Trump whom she eyeballed since
the administration has pulled out of the
UN climate pact how dare you you have
stolen my dreams in my childhood with
your empty words but the leader of the
worldwide teen movement for climate
action directed her anger at a broader
target even than the United States she
tore into everybody people are suffering
people are dying entire ecosystems are
collapsing we are in the beginning of a
mass extinction and all you can talk
about is money
and fairytales of eternal economic
growth how dare you
but money is what it will take to try to
slow climate change the UN summit was
called to prod countries to raise their
pledges on how quickly they will cut
back on the use of fossil fuels there
were larger pledges but not enough to
slow the warming to the required levels
here in Monaco a draft of the latest
report on climate change says the
melting ice in the polar regions has
accelerated to the point where it is
increasingly likely that sea level rise
may force hundreds of millions of
coastal dwellers from their homes this
century according to people in the world
climate change may be so advanced and
gone beyond so many tipping points that
some of the more severe consequences
flooding severe storms droughts may
already be inevitable global warming
like the arguments goes on Anthony Mark
Phillips in Monaco this morning thank
you Mark